[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Good
morning, everybody.
How's everybody doing?
Nice long weekend
we just came from--
I'm doing well.
I'm actually getting
over a little cold.
Aw-- yeah, unfortunately.
But after this, I don't have
anything else this week,
so that's good.
OK, so last time, last
week, we talked about how--
we looked at the search
problem that we talked about
earlier that week
and showed that,
in a certain model
of computation,
where I could only compare
two objects that I'm
storing in my--
that I'm storing and
get some constant number
of outputs on what I could--
how I could identify
these things,
like equal, or less
than, or something
like that, then we
drew a decision tree
and we got this bound
that, if I had n outputs,
I would require my decision tree
to be at least log n height.
And so in this model, I
can't find the things faster
than log n time.
But luckily, we are in a
model of computation which
has a stronger operation--
namely, random accessing.
And if we stored the things
that we're looking for,
we have unique keys, and
those keys are integers.
Then, if I have an
item with key K,
if I store it at
index K in my array,
then I can find it and
manipulate it in constant time.
That's pretty cool.
That's what we called
a direct access array.
A direct access array--
really not different
than a regular array,
except how are you using it
when we were talking
about sequences is we
are giving extrinsic
semantics to the slots where
we are storing these things.
Basically, I could put
any item in any slot.
Where it was in my
array had nothing
to do with what
those things were.
Here we are imposing intrinsic
semantics on my array
that, if I have an item with
key K, it must be at index K.
That's the thing that we're
taking advantage of here.
And then we can use this nice,
powerful linear branching
random access operation to find
that thing in constant time,
because that's our
model of computation.
OK, then what was the problem
with this direct access array?
Anyone shout it out.
Space-- right.
So we had to instantiate
a direct access
array that was the size
of the space of our keys.
In general, my
index location is--
could go from 0 to
some positive number.
If I a very large positive
numbers, if I was sorting--
if I was searching
among your MIT IDs,
I'd have to have a
direct access array that
was that spanned that space of
possible keys you could have.
And that could be
much larger than n.
And so the rest of the
time we talked about how
to fix that space problem.
We can reduce the space by
taking that larger key space
from 0 to u, which
could be very large,
and map it down
to a small space.
Now, in general, if I give you
a fixed hash function there,
that's not going to be
good in-- for all inputs.
If your inputs are very well
distributed over the key space,
then it is good, but
in general, there
would be hash functions with
some inputs that will be bad.
That's what we argued.
And so for the rest
of the time there,
we talked about hash families,
choosing a hash function
randomly from among a large
set of hash functions,
which had a property that, if
I chose this thing randomly
and you, generating your
input, didn't know which random
numbers I was picking, the
expectation over my random
choice-- me--
I'm the one running
the algorithm,
not you giving me the input--
that random choice--
my algorithm
actually behaves really
well in expectation.
In particular, I
got constant time
for finding, inserting,
and deleting into this data
structure, in expectation.
We did a little proof of--
that the chain links where we
stored collisions in our hash
function-- in our hash table--
sorry-- those
wouldn't be very long,
and so if they were
constant, then I
don't have to search more than
a constant number of things
when I go to an-- a
hashed index location.
Does everyone remember what
we talked about last week?
I didn't show you
this chart at the end,
but I'm showing it to you now.
Essentially, what we had was we
have a bunch of different ways
to deal with this set interface.
And last week, we talked
about the sorted array,
and then we talked about this
direct access array and this
hash table, which do better for
these dictionary-- the find,
and insert, and
delete operations--
or at least better
in an expected sense.
What's the worst case
performance of a hash table?
If I have to look up
something in a hash table,
and I happen to choose a bad
hash table-- hash function,
what's the worst case here?
What?
n, right?
It's worse than a sorted
array, because potentially, I
hashed everything
that I was storing
to the same index
in my hash table,
and to be able to
distinguish between them,
I can't do anything more
than a linear search.
I could store another set's
data structure as my chain
and do better that way.
That's actually
how Java does it.
They store a data
structure we're
going to be talking about
next week as the chains
so that they can get,
worst case, log n.
But in general, that
hash table is only good
if we're allowing--
OK, I want this to be expected
good, but in the worst case,
if I really need that
operation to be worst case--
I really can't afford
linear time ever
for an operation of that kind--
then I don't want
to use a hash table.
And so on your p set 2,
everything we ask you for
is worst case, so
probably, you don't
want to be using hash tables.
OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does
the subscript e mean?
JASON KU: What does
That's great.
In this chart, I put a subscript
on this is an expected runtime,
or an A meaning this is
an amortized runtime.
At the end, we talked about
how, if we had too many things
in our hash table, then, as long
as we didn't do it too often--
this is a little
hand wavey argument,
but the same kinds of ideas
as the dynamic array--
if, whenever we got a linear--
we are more than a linear factor
away from where we are trying--
basically, the fill factor
we were trying to be,
then we could just completely
rebuild the hash table
with the new hash
function randomly
chosen from our hash
table with a new size,
and we could get
amortized bounds.
And so that's what Python--
how Python implements
dictionaries, or sets, or even
objects when it's trying to
map keys to different things.
So that's hash tables.
That's great.
The key thing here is, well,
actually, if your range of keys
is small, or if
you as a programmer
have the ability to choose
the keys that you identify
your objects with,
you can actually
choose that range to
be small, to be linear,
to be small with
respect to your items.
And you don't need a hash table.
You can just use a
direct access array,
because if you know your key
space is small, that's great.
So a lot of C
programmers probably
would like to do something
like that, because they
don't have access to--
maybe C++ programmers would
have access to their hash table.
Any questions on this
stuff before we move on?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So why is [INAUDIBLE]?
JASON KU: Why is it expected?
When I'm building,
I could insert--
I'm inserting these things from
x 1 by 1 into my hash table.
Each of those
insert operations--
I'm looking up to
see whether that--
an item with that key already
exists in my hash table.
And so I have to look down
the chain to see where it is.
However, if I happen to
know that all of my keys
are unique in my input, all
the items I'm trying to store
are unique, then I don't
have to do that check
and I can get worst
case linear time.
Does that make sense?
All right.
It's a subtlety, but
that's a great question.
OK, so today, instead of
talking about searching,
we're talking about sorting.
Last week, we saw a
few ways to do sort.
Some of them were quadratic--
insertion sort and selection
sort--
and then we had one
that was n log n.
And this thing, n log
n, seemed pretty good,
but can I do better?
Can I do better?
Well, what we're going to show
at the beginning of this class
is, in this
comparison model, no.
n log n is optimal.
And we're going to go
through the exact same line
of reasoning that
we had last week.
So in the comparison
model, what did we
use when we were trying
to make this argument
that any comparison
model algorithm was going
to take at least log n time?
What we did was
we said, OK, I can
think of any model in
the comparison model--
any algorithm in the comparison
model as kind of this--
some comparisons happen.
They branch in a
binary sense, but you
could have it generalized to
any constant branching factor.
But for our purposes,
binary's fine.
And what we said was that
there were at least n outputs--
really n plus 1, but--
at least order n outputs.
And we showed that--
or we argued to you that
the height of this tree
had to be at least log n--
log the number of leaves.
It had to be at least
That was the height
of the decision tree.
And if this decision tree
represented a search algorithm,
I had to walk down and
perform these comparisons
in order, reach a leaf where
I would output something.
If the minimum height of any
binary tree on a linear number
of leaves is log n,
then any algorithm
in the comparison model
also has to take log n time,
because it has to do that many
comparisons to differentiate
between all possible outputs.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So in the sort problem, how
many possible outputs are there?
What is the output of
a sorting algorithm?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: What?
What's up?
A list-- in particular,
given my input--
some set of items
A that has size n--
what I'm going to give you is
some permutation of that list.
So for each index, say, I
could tell you where it goes.
Another way I could say is,
where does the first item
go to, where does
the second item go
to, where does the third
item go to-- blah, blah,
blah-- like that.
So how many different choices
of a permutation are there?
Well, how many choices do I have
for the first thing of where
it could be in the
final sorted array?
It could be in any of
the places, so it's n.
How about this one,
the second one?
Well, it can't go to
where this one went,
right but it can
go anywhere else.
So it's n minus 1.
And since these are
independent choices I'm making,
if I multiply them
all together, I
get 9 factorial
permutations that
are the number of
possible outputs
that I have to my
sorting algorithm.
So for me, to have an output
to my sorting algorithm
be correct, I need at
least n factorial leaves.
Does that make sense?
OK.
The nice thing about
doing this last week
is this is really just
the number of leaves
and this is really
the number of leaves.
So what's the number of
leaves is theta n factorial.
Here it's actually n
factorial, but I'm just
going to put it there.
And here we get an n factorial.
I see.
So it's at least
omega n factorial.
Does that make you happier?
Theta here-- thank you--
has to be at least.
So this was right.
OK, so at least this many--
there are algorithms
that, if it got--
it could take two
different routes
to get to the same output.
So this is a lower bound
on the number of leaves.
OK?
So what this
argument is saying is
that, if I just replace
the number of leaves n here
with n factorial, I get
a similar comparison
sort lower bound now.
So what is log of n factorial?
This is familiar
from p set 1 maybe.
So one thing I could do is I
could put in Sterling formula,
right?
And that'll give me something
of the form n log n.
But what's another way I
could lower bound n factorial?
Well, I have a bunch
of things here.
That's n factorial.
Half of these things--
these half, n/2 things--
are bigger than or equal to n/2.
That make sense?
So I can certainly lower bound
this thing by n/2 to the n/2.
That's a little easier
thing to take a log of.
If you take a log of that,
that's asymptotically n log n.
So what we're getting here
is any sorting algorithm here
takes at least n
log n comparisons,
and so a merge sort's
the best we can do.
That make sense to everybody?
We're just piggybacking on the
analysis we had about decision
trees, connecting leaves
with the minimum height
of any binary tree on
that number of leaves,
and just replacing
n with n factorial--
nothing super interesting here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the n over 2.
JASON KU: Yeah, sure.
You can just plug
in Sterling formula,
but I did this, so I
might as well clarify.
There are n terms
here in the product.
Half of them are at least n/2.
Does that make sense?
I can lower bound this
product by something
smaller than half of the terms--
a product of that,
and that'll be fine.
So I'm taking n/2 of them and
I'm multiplying n/2 altogether,
n/2 times.
Does that make sense?
It's just providing
a lower bound.
I just need something
that's smaller
than all of these terms.
And multiply them all
together, and that'll
give me a lower bound.
OK, so we can't do better than
n log n in the comparison model,
but what we did
last week was use
random access and a direct
access array to do better.
OK?
Can anyone think of how to
use that idea to sort faster?
And I'm going to give
you a caveat here.
I'm going to let you assume that
the keys of the things you're
trying to sort out are unique.
And say they're in a
bound-- in a small range.
So how could I use a direct
access array to sort faster?
Any ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could
you just literally
insert [INAUDIBLE] into
a direct access array?
JASON KU: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: And then you look at
that array and how to sort it.
JASON KU: OK.
So what your colleague is
saying is exactly correct.
It's something that I like to
call direct access array sort.
We won't really call it that,
because there's something more
general that we'll talk
about in just a second.
But what your colleague
was saying is,
instantiate a big
direct access array--
direct access array sort.
I'm instantiating
this big direct access
array of the space
of my keys, and what
your colleague was
saying was I take
each one of the items in my--
the things that
I'm trying to sort,
I look at each
one of their keys,
and I stick it in
the direct accessory
exactly where it needs
to go, in constant time.
That's great.
Now, I gave you this caveat
that all the keys were unique,
so I don't have to deal
with collisions here.
But then, after I'm done with
this, all of these things
are now in sorted
order, and what I can do
is I can just walk
down this list.
A lot of these cells
are empty, potentially.
Some of the keys might
not be there, but what
I can do is just
walk down this list,
pick off every item that does
exist, stick them in an array--
I'm done.
Stick a key into here and then--
all right.
Make direct access array.
Store items-- item
x in index x.key.
Walk down direct access array,
and return items seen in order.
Does that make
sense to everybody?
All right, how long
does this step take?
Building a direct
access array order u--
OK, so this is order u--
how long does this take?
How many items you
have to insert?
Order n, or just n--
and how long does it take to
insert each one of these things
into my direct access array?
Worst case constant time--
so this is n times worst
case constant time--
great.
How long does this
last one take?
Anyone?
O of u also-- right,
because I'm walking down
the entire length of u.
So this algorithm takes,
in total, n plus u time.
This is great.
u is bigger than n, because
we assumed distinct keys.
But if u is on the
order of n, then we now
have linear time
sorting algorithm.
Yes?
What's up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: I'm sorry.
You have to speak up.
AUDIENCE: How do you attach
keys to the [INAUDIBLE]??
JASON KU: How do I attach
keys to my inputs in my--
for a set data structure that
we've been talking about,
all of my items have keys.
That's just something that
we impose on our input.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Each of the
keys is-- in this case,
it has to be a number.
That's a nice point.
We do this to talk about
sorting items generally so
that we don't have to deal with
potentially if these keys have
values associated with--
or other stuff associated--
put them on that item, and
they'll still be there.
But in general, if you just
wanted to sort integers,
you could say that .key is--
points back to
the object itself,
if you want to just
sort some integers.
Does that make sense?
It's a good question, though.
OK, so that gives us a
linear time algorithm
when u is small, and
under this condition
that I have unique keys
when I want to sort.
Those are fairly
restrictive, so we
might want to generalize
this a little bit.
OK?
So that's direct
access array sort.
What if we had a set of keys
that was a little larger?
So let's say u is theta n
implies linear time sorting.
That's great.
So now, what happens if we
expand that range a little bit?
Say u is less than or
equal to n squared--
maybe just less than.
OK, this is a bigger range
And if we instantiated
a direct access array
of quadratics size,
we'd have a quadratic
time algorithm.
This is not helpful.
Anyone have a way in which
we could sort integers that
are between 0 and n squared?
Maybe using the stuff
that we had above--
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sort by the first n,
kind of like the first digit.
JASON KU: Your colleague
is saying exactly
the thing that I'm looking
for, which is great,
which is maybe we could break
this larger number into two
smaller numbers.
Any integer that is between 0
n squared can be written as--
key can be some a and b, where
a is essentially the higher n
and b is the lower n.
This is kind of weird.
OK, so what do I
actually mean by this?
I mean that let's let a be
K, when I divide it by n--
integer, the floor-- key
integer to divide by n.
And b equals K mod n.
So this is a number that's
less than n and this is
a number that's less than n.
Does that make sense?
And actually, I can
recover K at any time
by saying K equals an plus b.
I've essentially decomposed
this into a base n
representation of this number.
And I have two digits
in that number.
This is the n-th--
n digit, and this
is the ones digit.
Does that make sense?
All right, so now let's say
I have this list of numbers--
17, 3, 24, 22, 12.
Here I have five numbers.
So what's n in this case?
5-- OK, not so interesting.
n is 5 here.
And I'm going to represent
this as five pairs of numbers
that are each within
the bounds of 0 to 4.
Does that makes sense?
So what is my a, b
representation of 17?
3, 2-- OK.
Yeah, so there are
3 times 5 plus 2.
That's good.
That's 17.
Yeah?
I think your colleague
did that, right?
I have all of
these written down,
so I'm just going
to write it out.
And I hope I did it correctly.
OK-- 3, 2; 0, 3;
4, 4; 4, 2; 2, 2--
OK.
So now I have a bunch
of things that I
want to sort based on
this function that I have.
These are no longer just
integers that I need to sort.
I need to sort by this
transformation of this thing
into a number.
Does that make sense?
So anyone have any
ideas on how we could--
by the way, these are both
constant time operations
on your computer, as long
as it's an integer division
and this is mod.
Python also has a
nice thing, I think,
in its standard operations,
which is divmod of K, n.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So if you want to
use that, you can.
OK, so how do we
sort these tuples?
These are tuples, right?
You guys are, I'm sure, very
familiar with tuples by now.
How do I sort these tuples?
What's the most important
digit of this thing?
If I had to sort
one of the digits
and get something
that's close to sorted,
what's more important-- the
1's digit or the n's digit?
OK, we have discrepancy here.
Who says 1?
Who says n?
Someone who said n tell me why.
Oh, you all think that
way for no reason.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
Sorry.
This is a little confusing.
This is the 1's digit.
This is the n's digit.
This is the 1's digit
in how I'm writing this.
Does that makes sense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] have
a different ones digit
inside of it.
So you could have
[INAUDIBLE] but
that only tells you where
they are with regard
to the specific n
category they're in.
So it's more of a [INAUDIBLE].
JASON KU: Yeah.
So what your colleague is
saying is exactly correct.
I could vary b all I want
right with the same a.
If I change a by 1,
it doesn't matter what
b is-- it's going to be bigger.
Does that make sense?
The K is much more
sensitive to a
than it is to b, so a is
more important than b.
Does that make sense?
So if I just wanted to get
some linear time algorithm,
I could just sort by
their bigger digits
and hope they don't differ very
much on the smaller things.
I've kind of sorted
these things.
Does that make sense?
OK.
What if I actually want
to sort these things?
Any hints?
Yeah?
I need to sort on
both, in some sense.
What I'm going to
tell you right now
is an algorithm that I
like to call tuple sort,
but you can also think of it
as Excel spreadsheets sort.
I have an Excel spreadsheet
of a bunch of data.
I have a prioritization on how
important the keys are to me--
the columns.
And if I have a very
important column and an order
of the columns of how
important they are to me,
I can repeatedly
sought on the columns
until they're sorted
based on my preference.
That's something that
you may have done.
Now, if I have an ordering on
the preferences of my columns,
do I start by
sorting all of them
on the most important thing
or the least important thing?
What?
Who says most?
Who says least?
There's discrepancy here.
All right, let's try it out.
All right, tuple sort--
let's start by sorting
these things by least
significant first, and then--
no, most significant first
and then least significant.
That was the first thing
I asked you, right?
All right, so these are the
most significant things,
the first ones.
And these are the less
significant things.
All right, instead of
writing it as tuples,
I'm going to write them
as 32, 03, 44, 42, 22.
Is everyone cool that?
This is just base
five representation.
All right, so let's start by
sorting all of these things
by the most significant
thing, which
is by this guy, this guy, this
guy, this guy, and this guy.
So how do I do it?
The first one is 03, second one
is 22, the next one is 32, 42,
and then 44--
maybe 44?
I don't know.
Does it matter, the order
in which I put these things?
I don't know.
I'm just going to keep it
the same order for now.
All right, so I've sorted it
by the least significant--
or the most
significant-- sorry--
the leading term.
And now I'm going to sort
by the least significant.
So what's the least
significant here?
22-- then 2 is also--
this is also 2.
This is also 2.
This is 3.
And sorted list-- voila.
Why did that not work?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
So what happened is I
did take into account
the significant
digit sort, but when
I did the less significant
thing, it erased all of my work
from up here.
Does that make sense?
In the case of ties, we want
the more significant thing
to take precedence, so we
want to do that thing last.
Does that makes sense?
So the right way to do this--
this is the most significant
first [INAUDIBLE] not good.
All right, at least
significant first--
let's try that.
So least significant here is 2.
OK, so I see 32, 42,
22, 03, and then 44.
OK?
Sound good?
Least significant first--
now I do most significant.
I sort the most
significant thing.
OK, so what's the most
significant thing?
03, 22, 32-- most
significant four--
44, and 42-- cool.
We're sorted, right?
I did what you told me to do.
I sorted by the most
significant thing.
What's the problem here?
What did I do wrong?
You wanted me to put 42
here and 44 here, right?
Because 42 came first
in the input and 44
came second, right?
OK, if a sorting algorithm
maintains this property that,
if they are the same
thing, then the output
maintains their order from
the input to the output--
their relative order-- that's
what we call a stable sorting
algorithm.
And so if we have a stable
sorting algorithm when
we're doing tuple sort, when
we're sorting on different keys
or columns of a
set, we really want
to be using a stable
sorting algorithm.
Does that makes sense?
Because otherwise,
we may mess up
work we did before
in a previous sort
of the less significant things.
And so yes, we want a stable
sorting algorithm here,
because then we will end
up sorting our thing.
Does that make sense?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So what your
colleague is saying--
let's sort by most significant,
then look at all of the things
with one of those that are
the same, and now sort that.
That's something we could do.
How long would that take?
Well, let's say I didn't use
half of my more significant set
of digits.
Say I'm only using n/2 or--
that's not quite going
to get what I want.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Say again.
AUDIENCE: We'll take
n squared [INAUDIBLE]..
JASON KU: Yeah.
So what we're going to do, if we
have direct access array sort--
if I then go into each
one of these digits
and try to sort the
things that are in there,
that's going to take time.
It's going to take time
for each of those digits.
There might be a
ton of collisions
into one of the things, and
so I might take more time
to sort that than linear.
Does that make sense?
So I would prefer to do this
tuple sort kind of behavior,
sorting the smaller thing,
sorting the bigger thing.
And because I only have a
constant number of things
in my tuples, this is
important, because I only
have two things I'm
worried about here.
I only have to do two passes
of a sorting algorithm
to be able to sort
these numbers.
However, can I use direct
access array sort here?
What was the initial stipulation
I had on direct access array?
That the keys were unique--
that's exactly the opposite
of what we have here.
We have things that
could be the same.
So we give up--
can't do it.
What do we do instead?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: You've already said
the thing that I'm looking for,
so that's great.
Your colleague
said, why can't we
just put more things at a key?
Why can't we put a list there?
That's exactly what we do.
This is called counting sort.
And what we do here is we
still have this direct access
array of space u
minus 0 to u minus 1,
but instead of storing one
thing here at each key K,
we store a pointer to a chain.
This sounds like hashing, right?
But the important
thing is that I
need to make sure, as
I'm inserting things
in here, that I'm maintaining
the order in which they
came in.
I can't just throw
them willy nilly,
or else we have this problem
up here that we had before.
So I need what I would
say is sequence data
structure, something that will
maintain the order that I--
the extrinsic order
that I had when
I'm putting these things in.
So as I have multiple
things with K,
I'm going to put
them in the order.
I can put-- have a pointer to a
dynamic array or a linked list,
where I just add
things to the end.
And then, at the
end of my algorithm,
when I read off the
things, I can just
look at anyone that
has a non-empty data
structure under here and
read them off in the order
that they came.
Does that makes sense?
So for this example,
I'm just going
to do this last step
here from the first row
to the second row.
I'm going to have this direct
access array with 0, 1, 2, 3, 4
on the slots.
So how am I going to do
this counting sort now?
I have 32, 42, 22, 03, and 44.
I can take the first one, 32.
I'm sorting by the
most significant thing.
I stick it here--
32, and then 44--
42-- sorry-- 42, 22.
This is not so much different
yet then dynamic array--
direct access array sort.
But when we get
to this duplicate,
44 here, we now have two
things in this thing.
And because we are keeping
them in order in this sequence,
I'm appending to the end.
Then, when I go and read
off the different things,
then I'm returning them
in a stable way in the way
that I want them to be.
Does that makes sense.
And it's not
overwriting the work
I did on the lower
significant digits.
So how long does this take?
This also only takes
order n plus u,
because I'm instantiating
this thing of size u.
And then, how big are
these data structures?
Well, maybe I'm storing one, a
constant amount for each index.
So that's a u overhead.
And then I'm paying 1 for
every item I'm storing.
These things are
only the lengths.
The sum total of
their lengths is n,
because I'm only storing
n things in there.
So the total amount of
space, the total amount
of work I have to do is order--
I need to be able to
spend in constant time
and I need to be able to
cycle through these things,
iterate over them
in linear time.
But if I have that,
I get n plus u.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do
you ensure that,
within your linked list or
your dynamic-- those elements,
like four equals four--
how do you make sure
that those are sorted?
JASON KU: So your
colleague is saying,
how do I ensure that the
things in these lists,
where they collide, how do you
ensure that they're sorted?
I don't.
I just ensure that they came
in the order that they came.
But as long as I sorted the
lower order digits correctly
in the previous things,
then I'm assuming
that their order as
they come in will
be sorted, if they collide.
That's the assumption.
That's the reason why I'm
doing these building up
from the least
significant to the most
significant is so that I
know that, when they collide,
the underlying stuff there is
sorted already in the input.
Does that make sense?
Great-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this array
isn't as big as u.
It's as big as n.
JASON KU: I'm using a direct
access array on the keys--
oh, this is n.
So counting sort is
general for any u.
I just happened to pick u being
n in this case when I broke
this thing up into n squared.
But this general concept is--
doesn't matter what
I choose for u.
Does that make sense?
OK.
But we will use that
right now to sort
larger ranges of numbers.
This was exactly the idea.
We're going to combine
tuple sort, use counting
sort as its auxiliary sorting--
stable sorting algorithm to do
all its work on these digits.
And so to sort of on n
squared size numbers,
I get linear time,
which is great,
because u is n in this case.
But can I extend that?
What if I had n cubed?
What if I had up to size u
equals n cubed, or less than n
cubed?
How many digits
would I have there?
How many size n digits
what I need to represent
a number of size n cubed?
Any ideas?
What did we do here?
We divided off an n.
We took it and stored it.
We're left with
something of size n.
If I had a number of size n
cubed, I could divide off an n.
I'm left with
something of n squared.
I don't know how to deal
with something of n squared.
Actually, I do.
I can split it up into
two size n numbers.
So if I had numbers bound--
upper bounded by a cubic--
n cubed-- I could split
it up into three digits.
Three is still constant.
And so I could split it
up into three digits,
tuple sort them in their
increasing priority,
and sort those.
Again, I'm doing
linear work per digit.
I have a constant
number of digits,
so I get a linear
time algorithm.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When it comes
to sorting [INAUDIBLE]----
JASON KU: Uh-huh.
AUDIENCE: Are you ensuring
that that runtime is also
big O of n plus u?
JASON KU: Yeah.
So it's always going to
be big O of n plus u,
but because I'm bounding
my digit size to be n,
u is n there, and so
I'm getting linear time.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So the idea here--
this is what we call radix sort.
Radix sort-- break up
integers, max size u,
into a base and tuple.
So basically, each one of my
digits can range from 0 to n.
How many base n digits do if
I have a number of size u?
Yeah, log n of u--
number of digits is log n of u--
log base n of u.
And then tuple sort on
digits using counting sort,
from least to most significant--
that's the algorithm.
How long does that take?
How long does it take
to sort on a digit that
spans the key 0 to n?
Linear time, right?
Order n time-- how many times
do I have to do this tuple sort?
The number of
digits times, right?
So the running time
of this algorithm--
first, I have to do this stuff,
break up each of the integers.
That takes n time--
n times the number of digits.
I had to create each
one of these tuples--
so n plus n times the
number of digits--
log base n of u.
So here I had to loop
through all the things.
And then here, for each
thing, I broke it up
into log base n of
u digits, and that's
how long the first thing took.
And then, how long did
it take me to tuple sort?
n time per digit--
so I also get this factor.
Does that make sense?
How long is that?
Is that good?
Is that bad?
For what values of u
is this linear time?
If u is less than n to
the c for some constant c,
then the c comes out of the
logarithm, log n of n is 1,
and we get a linear
time algorithm.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So that's how we can
sort in linear time,
if our things are only
polynomially large.
So in counting sort,
we get n plus u.
In radix sort, we get also
a stable sorting algorithm
where the running time is n
plus n times log base n of u.
Does that makes sense?
And then, in the
situations where--
there's a typo there
in counting sort--
that should be
when u is order n--
counting short runs
in linear time.
And it's linear time also
in the case of rating sort,
if our things are bounded
by a polynomial in n,
by n to the c for
some constant c.
Does that make sense?
All right, so that's how
to sort in linear time,
with the caveat that your
numbers aren't too big.
OK, see you next week.